hello i'm putting together a little vlog
for you that i thought was interesting
maybe it's not i haven't edited it yet
so we'll see
if that opinion still stands
[Music]
oh no happiness goes help if you didn't
know now you know your life is different
now i thought i'd do a little vlog that
gives you some
little bits and pieces of some of the
things i got up to this week all of them
are a bit cryptic uh but also super fun
and then we finish it off with some
really stress-free cooking i say that
because it
wasn't exactly like that but the rewards
of the actual cooking
reduced my stress greatly so enjoy this
little vlog piecemeal of some stuff and
some things good
morning i haven't really talked to
anyone this morning so
how to clear out
the throat caves make some space for the
noise there or the noise bats rather
they just fly through the caves who
knows what direction they're going in
it's monday morning i'm going to a set
today because mamrie and i are shooting
a little pilot of a web series that i
hope gets picked up for more episodes
but today we're shooting just the pilot
but um i don't know if i can tell you
anything about it which
you know is the most annoying thing
people do on these platforms but maybe
i'll show you some of the set when we
get there i haven't been on set
shooting something with a crew
even though this crew is very small in
like
years uh-oh get ready crew
for a
an unpracticed
socializer about to ooze her
awkward discomfort and over compensation
at trying to be comfortable vibes all
over your set here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello good morning from the greatest
angle known to human beings it is 10 a.m
exactly right now and we are in palm
springs there's some palms
i feel sprung because our house the
highball house which we've officially
named down here in palm springs is
officially done getting its gorgeous
makeover from our dear friend claire and
so we're shooting some content some
photos all the new after elements that
you do when something
human or
house gets a makeover and we've been up
very early this morning driving down to
palm springs and it's been
actually a gorgeous drive can't wait to
see the house maybe i'll show you some
of it
and maybe from better angles than
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
clear to this chance for five thousand
dollars there's so much to choose from
in our market
hello and welcome to it's now monday
uh afternoon 2 18 p.m and uh monday's
usually a day that i do school work all
day which i've been doing i've been
reading all morning about the psyche and
the unconscious
uh
materials that all go on in there it's
very just light-hearted and uplifting
and fun and it's a gray beautiful
lighthearted uplifting day in los
angeles so i thought i'd take a break
and make some lunch i'm uh setting up to
look everything's set up there's goose
down there very upset so i'm gonna
switch cameras and we're gonna cook some
hello fresh lunch together how about
that you have no choice unless you click
off in which you
have done by now if you did and if you
didn't wow my makeup does not blend in
well because my allergies i blow my nose
all the time
perfect we'll go from this angle perfect
is it going to be in focus i dearly hope
so it is dreary winter weather here in
los angeles and what nurtures the body
brain soul spirit all of that more than
soup italian garden veggie soup is what
we're making and i'm gonna make sure
that my audio is going and then i have
bread and cheese i'm gonna make some
grilled cheeses with it see that's what
you can go above and beyond you can
customize your hello fresh meals any way
you want to but before we do that let's
get into some talking points we all have
talking points they get right to the
point of any kind of talking hellofresh
is america's number one meal kit has
more five-star uh reviews than any other
meal kid out there so strengthen numbers
it's written in the stars and this
season they have all sorts of comforting
flavors available for you they have
recipes like chicken ramen and show you
style broth which i've made before and
is so delicious and peppercorn crusted
beef tenderloin which make it a
no-brainer to skip on ordering out you
can make it yourself and impress
everyone that seems unimpressible around
you and that's
a point i will press
that all we want to do is impress
everyone they offer 50 menu and market
items you can choose from every week
including recipes that are vegetarian
calorie smart gourmet so all those types
of people that prefer those types of
things will be equally impressed have i
stressed this enough and obviously the
recipes come with all the ingredients
pre-portioned so that means there's less
food waste there's less time wasted i'm
gonna stop wasting your time we're gonna
into making this recipe everything comes
in these beautiful brown paper bags
which usually contain no eggs and this
one is one of
those usual suspects no eggs can you
imagine if that's how
a gynecologist were to let you know how
fertile you are here are your results
no eggs never mind
i just got so excited about grilled
cheese and soup that's like
the perfect meal that combines what old
people and babies like
which is kind of what i feel like i am
right now oh my god okay all of this is
gonna go in all of me step number one is
we have to wash and dry all of our
produce hello produce
you seem pro to deuce what do you call a
carrot that loves
fresh butthole
produce operating at the height of our
intelligence today dice our onion cut
our carrots mince our garlic and remove
any of the large stems from the kale
let's peel these carrots
we all see it
carrots have a difficult time in this
world okay
they didn't choose to look like this and
yes i did choose to have a very immature
sensibility of the world but hey i'm
working on it okay let's get a knife
from the basement what are you doing
down here great okay no go escape and
look this doubles as trash that's my
real housewives tagline i love soup
because it's one of those foods that's
there for you when you're struggling and
also like when you're doing well it's
very grounding it's not like let's rage
food half peel and dice the onion oddly
satisfying
you have strong opinions on soup i guess
okay mincer
garlic now we are going to heat a
drizzle of oil in a large pot and we're
going to add the onions and carrots
season them with salt and pepper and
cook them four to six minutes
large pot oil large drizzle goes in
carrots and onions go in come on they're
waiting for you you're wanted at the
ball salt and pepper now those are gonna
party for a little bit and we are going
to be right back they've been cooking so
now we're going to stir in the italian
seasoning and the garlic and we're going
to cook for 30 seconds before we add all
of our other
[Music]
now what are we doing we are going to
add a crushed tomato three cups of water
and more salt oh stop concentrate and
stock concentrate read twice
at once
[Applause]
[Music]
gorgeous i guess i mean it's red water
we're gonna bring to a boil and then
reduce to a simmer and let the carrots
cook until they're softened for five to
seven minutes what can i do in the
meantime so this recipe came with bread
to make garlic bread
but i think i'm going to use the bread
we have and make grilled cheese
sandwiches i'm gonna do that i have a
hard time making decisions anyone else
going through that right now
everything's kind of out of control so
i've developed this really
intense habit of just not being able to
make a decision but we're gonna do that
let me make sure we have cheese ah
crap singles so our soup has been
simmering it's now on to the next step
but we're gonna add the couscous
and the kale and then we're gonna let
that cook for eight to ten minutes and
then season again with salt and pepper
tis the season to continuously season in
the meantime i'm going to construct our
grilled cheese sandwiches which are very
complicated advanced sophisticated i
just put butter on both the outside
pieces cheese in the middle put it in a
pan one side other side done it's like a
jersey girl to tanning salon cover the
front back with the spread get in the
hot
pan one side other side done we have
craft singles which come individually
wrapped which
is lovely because it gives you extra
time when you're unwrapping it just
think about what you're doing do you put
i mean there's so much butter you don't
need to add extra oil to the pan itself
right should we put a little extra
butter in the pan we're gonna do it okay
let's peel our cheese oh my god
this is exactly what i wanted oh my god
a matching pear we're just gonna let all
that cook until it's done where's my
other
spatula
yeah maybe i should have put something
oh god how did i ruin this it's i should
have put non-stick stuff down
oh my god
pick up this grilled cheese i thought it
was unstoppable maybe i turned it too
quickly
oh that's so sad how how did the butter
act as a glue
what the hell i complimented you pan we
were rooting for you we were all rooting
for you this is truly
a sad moment how has this happened this
way
okay we're gonna try it again
how have i how how how how i am baffled
beyond a disappointment at least the
soup is gonna be good in the meantime
are you curious about the deal with
hellofresh that you get if you're
interested i bet you are okay if you're
interested in getting meals that you
can't because there's instructions on
how to do them you can go to
hellofresh.com use my code hellbig14 to
get 14 free meals plus three free gifts
across five hellofresh boxes again
hellofresh.com use my called helbig14 to
get up to 14 free meals plus three free
gifts across five hello fresh boxes i
have i can't believe i've done this so
terribly let's put some soup into things
you eat soup out of bowls and then we
put some parmesan cheese on top of the
soup
[Music]
that's how she looks in her profile
picture and that's how she shows up and
you're like okay
okay and then she's like hey my friends
are waiting in the car and you're like
what the [ __ ] wow okay there's a chance
that we'll eat those later let me try
this soup
all right subscribe soup is great thank
god soup is great thank god this food is
comforting because i need to be
comforted i don't know look i can't help
myself i'm trying one okay look at
that is
so sad maybe we shouldn't judge a book
by its cover though
it tastes like hot crispy bread and
melted craft singles which technically
was the goal so that will get eaten
okay okay